this episode of true news is sponsored
by surf shark as we have been a few
items you might remember we've been
sponsored by surf shark again
these guys have looked after us they
they support true news
you have to support them and you're also
going to be supporting yourself
by using the surf shot because surf
shark is an app and browser extension
which basically allows you to place
yourself anywhere in the world so you
can look at
any content from around the world or say
look at stuff that you don't want people
looking at you
looking at spying right yeah you don't
want people looking at you while you're
looking at
a dirty internet video that means you
gotta look after yourself you've got to
protect yourself you've got to wear
protection and that's what surf shock is
great it's a condom for the internet
what's your favorite shark great white
not on a racial level though no if there
was a great black one i'm sure i'd enjoy
that one as well yeah just to be clear
so say you want to watch i don't know
netflix in another country
you can do you know why surf shark
sometimes i i finished netflix in the uk
i've literally
literally watched everything especially
i've just had a kid right so you might
be sitting at home with a kid or maybe
you're looking after your little brother
or sister or something you're like i
need something new to watch
oh you're just on your own lonely no
friends yeah you might not have a family
or a loved one or a future in a
relationship maybe you're crying over
that alone at home you think [__] what's
going to take my mind off it italian
netflix
right brilliant yeah don't go to french
netflix romantic for me you'll always
have paris
here's the other thing as well you know
when you're on holiday and you're abroad
oh you can go and watch
english stuff and go watch english stuff
you know that's normally a problem yeah
that's normally a product
i know not many people are sorted
traveling right now but say that you
watch from outside the
uk as many of our audience does yeah bam
here we are thanks and obviously it
encrypts your data unless you stay
anonymous online what was the last dirty
thing you looked at online
pogs um p-a-w-g what does that mean
fat ass white girl oh not on a
discriminatory thing it was just i just
sort of
they all uh anyway we got an offer for
you so if you use code
geordie you can get 83 off plus three
months
free extra we also offer a 30-day
money-back guarantee so if you're not
happy with it just get your money back i
don't i mean
it's so little money that's confidence
from social media yeah exactly that's
confidence if you don't like it
have your money back anymore we can give
you an offer they're saying it was
confidence yeah it's all well and good
you signing up to surf shark we need
your parents we need your siblings
everyone around the table
you can't eat until you've all started
shark spread the word baby spread it
like cheeks and when your dad goes
martin not now you go 83 dad and three
months for free are you really gonna
ignore that yeah and your dad goes
past the peas and you go not until you
realize that there's a 30-day money-back
guarantee
you're gonna deny that yourself i'm not
sure you can be my father anymore
exactly yeah and then you
get up and smash the table yeah it's
over take the problem dress
surf shark stick it up your studs i want
your [__] blood money
[Music]
it's time for true news brilliant surf
shark
[Music]
food
i wonder if dana was a good looking guy
when he was younger he looked very
different
thank you very much james i appreciate
it we're very excited we got a sellout
crowd here
5 000 people revved
in a way though i feel like this is
great to show that when you're like
early 20s if that's him in his early 20s
that's one mean haircut for your early
20s
but the point i'm making is we all need
to go through
that glow up you wanted to be a fight
promoter and when you look back at
yourself when you start a journey to
when you end it you're going to be a
completely different person he's matured
do you know what
conor mcgregor's like the stamps yeah
you know how daniel feels
i empathize yeah there's more punch
lines there but i won't make them go for
it
no no no no i like my face so long story
short earlier this year conor mcgregor
wanted a few fights
in the ufc and one of those fights was
going to be against a guy called justin
gaichi right some of you might know he's
fighting khabib
very soon but the point was is dana
white alluded to the fact
that conor was not wanting that fight
now connor went and leaked the dms that
prove
he was after that fight and any other
fight you could get his hands on
and it was dana who was not actually
delivering the
opportunity dana white is pissed because
he's been outed as not telling the truth
now first of all here's my issue why the
[__] you doing this on instagram what
are you 12
any other mma fighter in the ufc pretty
much
has to have his people call their people
they take a while to get back to them
right and if you're lucky you get the
fight you want conor mcgregor
yeah just dm dana that's the level he's
at and that's another thing that dana's
probably pissed that is because every
other fighter
is now like is that how easy it is for
this guy yeah you know like it makes
everyone else feel
pretty [__] inferior and guess what
yeah
earlier this year dana white had a sex
tape controversy did you hear about that
i can't believe someone filmed a sex
tape with dana white and when
people will want to see this that's even
juicier the person
who was blackmailing dana who leaked the
sex tape was the boyfriend
of the girl who dana [__] so dana
basically would just fly this [__] out
there give her all the money
pay her for a [__] trip then she'd
[__] off back home with my boyfriend
right and it was sort of like
agreed dana white named this victim in
200 grand
sex tape extortion laws the guy was
called
ramos sergio good on you 42 year old
a real estate agent and personal trainer
pled guilty in federal court
extortion sorry he went to prison five
years ago and now
he hired a lawyer who was also a felon
to try and extort dana again for 10
million
you got no money from me last time and
you won't be getting any money from me
this time
wow i've got to admit i'm impressed by
this dude well done danny
did the guy know so this guy was in on
it yeah yeah he can't extort someone
after that
no dana's like look i'm slinging dick
your girlfriend
and you're gonna like it do you know how
many killers i know i'll send chocolate
down after you this is what happens when
you get any success
back in the day getting rich man people
would [__] you now it means
people will [__] you then try and [__]
you over brilliant so interestingly
connor's gone his own road now to try
and get a fight so he's in the last
seven days conor mcgregor has claimed to
be fighting
manny pacquiao brilliant in a boxing
match which the ufc would have to
sanction themselves because they owned
konosaurs dana's claim
have no knowledge of that conor's then
contradict them saying well you've seen
the legal people so that's bollocks
connor
zen in a matter of days later claimed to
be having this fight with dustin poirier
for charity
in dublin once again isn't sanctioned by
the ufc the ufc have then
offered him that fight in a cage and
said if you want to do it
let's do it connor's completely ignored
them and continue promoting this
as if it's going to happen connor's
getting the reputation as an absolute
[__] of these days like back in the
day if he said he was going to fight
someone
he was there part of this is the ufc's
fault as well i never know what the
[__] true now from two straight guys
beefing to two straight guys beefing
jeffree star and what looks like nars
who slimmed down
jeffree star basically went into nazi's
instagram comments
and said hey since you can't answer the
phone right now can you give me all the
stuff back you stole
from my house what kind of low life
[__] scum does that if you need a
return label just ask just to be clear
that isn't naz the rapper it's just his
ex-boyfriend
right and to be clear when he says what
kind of law life
scum does that you were getting used for
money the entire time
yeah right okay just be clear you know
you've got to ask yourself what kind of
person
becomes jeffree star's boyfriend a guy
who robs him i get that
maybe the whole relationship was a charm
right and it was just
let's steal from him while smashing his
back doors in a bit
i mean we don't know whose daughters
have been smashed and we don't know
whether i'm pretty sure
there was a moment where jeffree star
is riding his dick and then he pulls him
close starts cuddling him just steals
his earrings
jizz in his eyes oh oh i've blinded me
oh no
no no no no no no no no no no no no
right oh you better go and wipe them out
that's not the way you are going to
clean
more stuff in the bag and he's like well
our best be off no not the way it works
if you were going to come on someone's
face that person would definitely want
them to come on the face so while
jeffrey is loving it yeah
there's it's oh it's everywhere he's
just going you love that
this is uh first of all we've missed as
the banner at the top of the the orgy
the orgy collection imagine if brian
bought out a series of
uh palettes or clothes and we just
called it the [__] collection
what's up everybody welcome back to my
channel
you've got to say right this
[__] i mean that is literally
the face he makes
when a [__] was at results sure or when
he is having an orgy
in today's video it's time you guys
it is time jeffree star looks as if he's
slowly becoming
who's the bad guy in harry potter
voldemort voldemort right
and it's been a very crazy 2020. let's
just say that
crazy is 2020 been crazy crazy it's been
an orgy for you hasn't it you know
mid pandemic someone goes you know what
we need an
orgy palette how mental is that giving
people what they need right yeah exactly
we're begging for it jeffrey we're
begging give us something that the
people will love
are you going to give half of your next
pallets profits
to charity because people need them no
i'm just going to talk about
[__] everyone oh great okay well
that'll do also
i guess it's been a very interesting and
tumultuous
and insane 2020 but you guys we're gonna
survive we always do so
not everyone are going to survive yeah
that's what i love about it that's one
thing i do want to be absolutely clear
about if they can ever say that about a
year not everyone is getting out a live
chat
exactly yeah and to be fair there is no
year where everyone's lived all the way
through it all right
but this year in particular there are
less people living we're going to
survive we always do
yeah exactly jeffree star except the
people who are dead they're not
customers lawrence exactly
here's the other side though he's
covered both sides brian for dead people
genius brilliant i love the fact that
when the corpse of your loved ones
sitting there
in the chapel of rest yeah jeffrey starr
comes to give them one final glow up
before you lower them six foot
underground jeffrey what are you doing
i'm a necrophiliac that's what he would
have wondered yeah well jeffrey you're
smearing your [__] over his lips
trust me he wanted this not too sure
about that jeffrey so what he did do was
he made
christmas palette now again i'm just
gonna mind you mid-may
height of the pandemic the sky the
height of people
dying globally and he goes the cremated
palette
what a palette i love the fact that he's
sitting there going what's really on
trend right now i know uh
burning bodies learning bodies this is
happening everywhere
it's all the rage there you go cremated
the dust of your loved ones
all over your face literally there he is
apparently he's a basketball player
does he yeah no you can't be a good one
if you've not heard of him so the
aspiring
mba star went to austria is that where
korea's going to die is it when things
are on the up in
in your career you don't tend to go from
america to europe realistically austria
as well
it's hardly the pinnacle of any sport
you can make it there you can make it
anywhere austria
i'm sure a lot of y'all can relate but
sometimes when you meet people
surprise they're not who they say they
are says the man who literally puts a
face full of makeup on to look like
another person
so y'all real quickly jeffrey lynn got a
little play constantly in the third
person oh yeah well i mean
you do that when you're not on camera
brian lynn what the [__]
jeffree star got robbed no someone just
stole a few things now
i know jeffrey you can just rebuy it i'm
not complaining about no value with no
money it's just a principle i don't care
if someone steals a nickel off your
counter it's wrong this is the thing
this is the sad truth of the matter he's
gonna get these losers
just over and over it's novel though
it's like janella means it's a novel but
but they're just like maybe this guy
will take care of me pay the bills
and i'll just tolerate it you know what
i mean and one after another that is
exactly what happens to jeffree star
where he keeps
paying for these guys to live and then
eventually they're like
this isn't worth the money no do you
know and like that it's sad but that's
the reality jeremy if all you do is [__]
losers there's a reason behind it
sorry i love the fact that there's
people out there right now going oh
they're intriguing oh my god they look
across the boyfriend they're watching
you need standards for a reason and
we've all dipped at one point or another
but um
we got a we got a whole firm the next
story comes to us from
youtuber boogie2988 the guy or one of
the guys who inspired me to start
youtube he was really nice to me back in
the day always had a soft spot for him
but in the last couple of years things
have been a bit weird
like he's been accusing people of
terrorizing him
a lot of rumors have come out about him
you just don't know what's true and
what's fake but i i've always wished the
guy
the best he's very kind to you and you
yeah yeah absolutely
and um someone's turned up at his house
threatening him hey guys
i guess i should make a video about this
i need to be very careful
about what i say here because this is
now a criminal
investigation i don't know how the [__]
this has gotten this far but this crazy
bastard's turned up at his house
um and you'll see the way the guys are
going at it right this is real
i think come on you [__] [__] what's
the deal
where's the gun at you fat [__] the
funnier thing
and i'm i'm not wishing death upon this
eye it's weird because the guy's got a
t-shirt with
someone pointing a gun on it it seems
yeah from abercrombie and fitch where
only douchebag shop it would have been
actually funnier if just through the
door
he just i did shout out to my new friend
i wouldn't wish death on him but no for
the sake of the video it would have
looked sick it would have been [__]
incredible
[__] what's the deal cameron doesn't
have to go down this way buddy you're a
fat
[__] yeah you won't even open the door
oh i will
you know when people first start a tick
tock and they have to act both sides of
the role why does it look like
if the guy does look quite like is he
look as if buggies shot this from both
angles
he does look a bit like maybe that's why
the guy hates him so much because he
hates himself yeah and then what are you
going to shoot me
my roommate
you gonna shoot me no but my roommate
will i do rape boogies honestly even in
that
situation that's a really good point
yeah you're gonna kill me
i i guess so buddy just give me a second
to get my dog wrangled
you're a [__] [__] dude oh hold on
i'll show you a [__] bud
oh i got this [__] i got this [__] so
buggy why are they treating this like
some sort of siege it's one fat man
outside your house
but the guy is obviously mental yeah so
he might have a gun he might have a
knife when someone knocks on your door
like that they're probably not in a
good place especially when they have a
gopro on their head one second buddy
sammy
up i want to make sure my dog's
protected look i'm in a room man you can
see how kind someone's at the door
you can often judge a man by how he
treats his dog one second bud
one second he's treating it like it's a
pizza delivery guy
i bet he gets a lot of those things i'm
gonna ask you to leave this is my home
you are not welcome here you have
threatened my life
i'm asking you to leave in about 30
seconds i'm gonna fire a warning shot
and we'll fire it now this guy's gone to
the front door of someone else's house
and he's bullying him and then boogie
comes out with a gun this guy the guy's
a bully this is a nasty
if boogie would have blown his head
clean enough i would not have a problem
with it right yeah literally no problem
believe me that is my policy so go for
it son i'm all for
uh peacefully negotiating stuff no but
boogie's being peaceful the guy's being
an [__] but he's well within his
rights to shoot this [__] i'll give you
a warning shot the other guy's going
do it now like he's the joker i'd love
it
please don't make me do this you just
leave this property so i can leave
what's this guy got a gun
i'm just here looking at it because i
feel threatened this guy's about to kill
somebody right yeah
why are you on this property i'll shoot
to women i'll shoot a wound
you hear the the tone change in this
prick's voice
now it's real [__] saying please don't
do this
i don't know you gotta say buggy is
being
very calm in the situation he is calling
him sam but we don't know why whatever
the [__] his name is who gives a [__]
he's just some loser who turned up to
his [__] house regardless buggy
handled this as good as possible and
realistically the guys looked at you
didn't die because if you're being
converted
like that that's it shooty 2988 more
like
yeah we are embroidered in a little tiny
bit of a controversy with james charles
she's got a cool cap that cap's cool
i've got to give credit to ethan he's
punching beyond belief with
ela really yeah i mean she's a pretty
girl he's a funny guy but he's average
you know what i mean this happened to
guys who do podcasts in america they
become distinctly average looking guys
he's punching like any respect the man
should be right that i have nothing
personal about
james charles and my intention with this
of calling him out was not i don't i
really
i think i can actually summarize this
h3h3 released some hoodies not long
after that james charles also released
some hoodies which looked very similar
if not almost exactly the same james
charles
then was accused basically of stealing
in the designs james charles then
basically outed themselves not really
designing these things by saying listen
my designers just sent me a series of
designs
i just proved these things so really
james charles doesn't really give a [__]
about any of this stuff and just turns
out any old crap and his fans basically
go james charles designed this when
actually james cells didn't really
design anything he just went yeah that's
good h3h3 then replied and
it's some sort of [__] between them
no one really gives a [__] because it's
a
oh it's a hoodie that hoodie is like our
most
iconic piece i'm gonna be honest with
you right
i like to follow trends i don't always
dress in them this is a trend that's
coming anyway this kind of
you know they haven't even admitted that
they didn't
think of that first so what does it
matter what are they pissed off yeah
this collection is so different than
anything we've ever done before with
sisters first of all it is the first
time that we're ever
using a different font for the sister's
logo a different font james you're
spoiling us by just printing a word
unbelievable [__] [__] we all
have to suck these people off because
it's like well one day
they might might come on my podcast so
we all pretend
that we might like these people why
don't they do something i don't give a
[__] i mean he's very
outside of the idea that james might
give me an interview one day i don't
really care the point
i would make is i don't like him because
of the interview i just think out of all
of the top
all of that lot i find jeffree star very
annoying
i find him sort of mildly amusing i
could give a [__] either way but it's
that's part of it by the way if you like
everything everywhere there's something
wrong with you hate us we're asking you
for it
you just spit on us no
from one rainbow flavored youtuber to
another oh
i never yeah he's come out as bisexual
here's the thing
if you're going to do a video about
coming out as bisexual don't do the
title like that go
am i bisexual feeling a bit bi yeah
feeling
am i feeling a bit bi sexuality the
biggest question
in the world am i gay or am i straight
and just fine robert patterson
very weirdly attractive do you find
robert pets
when i say someone's attractive it would
probably suggest that i want to [__]
them i'm attracted to them whereas
i can think that someone's good looking
but not be personally attracted right
like you and i think of each other i
look at you and i think he's a good guy
you know good teammate like that yeah
but i don't constantly think oh i want
to [__] brian in the ass not for all the
time anyway not all the time yeah
exactly
just occasionally we have to work pick
stopping up in front of you yeah exactly
so why not right hey man i'm not gay i
just find robert patterson
really really attractive i wonder what
robert patterson would think of him
if we have an interview and we'll ask
him for you what would batman think of
you you're going to be a good penguin
ironically
two years and we're going to see eye
nubber going back
is it colin farrell yeah it's not a dig
do you know me
they have made colin powell up quite
heavily in the video well they spend
less time on makeup
i'm sorry please don't hate me is that a
good kid it was a batman joke it was
there for the taker
can it not take that right yeah it's
more of a batty man joke
you're not allowed to say that anymore
but i went there so but yeah
basically um yeah
i'm bisexual when he said this i went
what's the news
let's be honest when you do youtube
videos about drama
yeah this implied didn't it when i saw
the video title i went don't need to
watch that
i thought i'd never say this but i'm
slightly worried
that people will get mad at me for
saying
i'm bisexual that makes sense because
it's such a precious thing
sexuality and the minute you try and
invade the other group they're like no
we don't want you
you can't be in here there's only so
many greedy people in this room pick a
side
you're either gay or straight all right
but when it comes to bisexuality
lgbtq plus it's just getting a bit too
many letters and then it's like plus
minus divide
yeah exit well i'd love to divide those
vertex and put something right in it do
you know what i mean
as juice so i thought why not take my
platform
and just speak about it i really respect
dynaber for speaking about something
that feels so personal on a channel
where he doesn't speak this way and i
get that he's uncomfortable yeah but i
think it's good because his audience
might be feeling like they want to say
something in their own life so this is
going to encourage other people to do
the same yeah it's like when people
watch true geordie video and then go
downstairs and go
mum dad i'm sorry but i'm a big fat
bastard
i really need to hear how he discovered
he was bi in 2017
i remember my friend was saying to me on
new year's eve that he is bisexual
and i thought to myself me too was he
saying it at
ten nine yeah bisexual just
i think i might be terrible we're just
too lonely straight guys right that
seems like a strange time
to realize it no it's a big time of
change it's like oh and you start for me
maybe next year i'll be
bisexual no but like surely the first
time you realize you're bisexual is when
you want to shag another man put it this
way you don't realize you're bisexual as
you're about to insert your penis into
another man's
ass i get it you know oh i'm bisexual
bye this is the thing bye bye i feel
like i nabba
may have just misread his friend's
signals and while his friend was being
honest with him what he was really
saying was top off
and i nabber instead of going yeah let's
uh let's see where that goes went
yeah me too should we get some more
drinks or something or a tuxedo
yeah yeah and his friend's just all
night going he's got like lollipops and
sort of little sausages
and then he's got one of those straws
that looks like a dick right yeah
remember that one he's like
yeah he's going up and down yeah and
adap is just going boy you must really
be thirsty
anyway he's completely misread the side
the entire the whole time i love it and
then he wakes up the next morning and
goes
i'm bisexual and then he turns over and
he goes hi honey
once again aside from the jokes well
proud of you mate well done hey put it
this way though if you are bisexual you
better get used to
being rejected by a group of guys do you
know what i mean like if anything it
makes life more complicated
it was a joke about how the e-boys
rejected him oh yeah
did you know yeah yeah yeah because
remember how four men not why they
rejected them yeah well no it's
strange considering who they went for
maybe that was part of it maybe they
were like
yeah we've got enough we've got enough
going on the car is full
all right yeah listen there's already
enough sexual tension here we don't need
someone in the middle going i'm bisexual
there won't be any boys wembley cup team
that's for sure because those showers
will be
action pockets well if anything that's
more reason to have a wembley cup evoice
team am i right
it must be hard though because for me
it's it's a very clear thing of like
women with big booties
for him there's just a whole variety of
stuff going on right yeah you might look
at anyone's crotch not necessarily ours
because bisexual people don't find all
people attractive exactly you might you
one day
could be looking at another man's [__]
and just go god i want to suck that
i mean to be fair it's not much of a
pivot from one subject to another really
is it well
ellen is the original um what's the word
okay you can't call it the original gay
uh the orgy
she's the orgy yeah that's good on tv
that is anyway
ellen has come out and done a kind of
like a response to all the [__] that
went on
people basically saying the treatment of
her staff
on the shore was awful yeah and it
shocked brian as well because he
realized
[__] i can't do that anymore let's see
her sort of the way she handled it
if you're watching because you love me
thank you if you're watching because you
don't love me welcome
one thing that really comes across about
this i watched a little bit of it before
i haven't watched this it's so forced
so desperately yeah and she's like
please love me again
i'm desperate but also like you can see
the guilt as well you can see that i
have done stuff wrong
how was everybody's summer good yeah
mine was great
this is a woman who used to be a
comedian and the delivery there is just
it's excruciating yeah she used to be so
funny but she used to be relatively
funny
for the time you know back when friends
was popular and stuff
as you may have heard this summer there
were allegations of a toxic work
environment at our show
and then there was an investigation i
learned that things happened here that
never should have happened sorry weren't
you the things that shouldn't have
happened she's the gaffer basically
yeah so yeah i i learned as if she was
completely unaware of it first
[__] people say ellen was the source
of it but yeah
we have had a lot of conversations over
the last few weeks about the show our
workplace and what we want for the
future
we have made the necessary changes and
today we are starting a new chapter
i'm quitting the show that's not her
taking responsibility
really at all we're just like we've made
the changes and now it's a new day
and moving on like yeah exactly yeah
imagine though like the type of [__]
that she was accused of and some of the
things that came out were
mental yeah this man is typing because
he's scared being known as the be kind
lady
is a tricky position to be in especially
when you're an [__] am i right listen
you put me in a tricky position here
because i'm not particularly nice yeah
all right
off camera yeah just a [__] yeah it's a
real problem yeah
it's a really hard position to be known
as such a positive message
i am that person that you see on tv i am
also a lot of other things i
sometimes i get sad i get mad i i get
anxious i get frustrated i get impatient
and i am working
on all of that i am a work in progress
her way of taking accountability for
this is to basically say i'm a work in
progress
sue me this is just a car crash to be
honest with you um i think any
credibility she once had
is just gone now because if you have
been accused of things
you have to directly address everything
you've been accused of
she has glossed over this you know like
she's on ice skates yeah she's just
floating over it she
she ain't actually tackling what she was
accused of at all i get that it's
sometimes
when you're a boss and you have a big
production you've got to be a bit of an
[__] to people occasionally that's
going to happen
not like the way that she was though but
yeah that's the point occasionally
you're going to ruffle some feathers
because that's part of running the
business but she
she hasn't tackled this at all so for me
i think you can just see in a face liar
i don't know in the long run i think it
has damaged quite a lot you can see it
in her face she's she's ruined from it
it's taken it out we welcome the
republican nominee president trump and
the democratic nominee
vice president pike this uh debate by
the way was all about diversity in the
united states as three
old men of a white background discussed
what they thought the future of the
country was it's all about diversity the
future that's all in the future
and you lot won't be here well no
jeffree star says we all we all will be
or we'll also be there yeah yeah exactly
yeah
there uh joe biden greeted his
competitor tonight as if he was seeing
an old family friend
hey there you are good to see you within
a minute he's calling on the club yeah
do you have any idea what this is
that's what family is though not only
that call of spade a spade do you know
what i mean
the fact is that everything he's saying
so far is simply a lie
i'm not here to call out his lies
everybody knows he's a liar but you i
just wanna
if you're going to say he's a liar
though at least at least let's say
say what he said in his life you know
right i want to make a president can you
let him finish sir
no he doesn't know how to do that he has
you know christ
you picked to be surprised the wrong
night at the wrong time listen you
agreed with him
he has the deal ladies and gentlemen
here's the deal joe biden's got the [__]
but biden might have a point in what
he's saying but what he needs to do
it's hard because if you does that old
saying isn't it don't argue with the
fool because from a distance people
can't tell who's who so
which one's the fool but the problem is
is biden can't pull him up on it he
hasn't actually got the the sharpness if
that was obama he'd be [__] all over
him right now boom it'll be like boogie
night two nine eight eight you just go
are you doing this or not yeah don't
make me do this trump yeah i don't want
to do that to be fair that's kind of
what joe biden was saying
i'm not going to answer the question
because yes because the question is
the question is honestly a debate you're
meant to be able to hear both sides
there are a number of times where i
can't even understand what i don't know
what this means
there was an offer from joe rogan to
moderate these two that he would have
done a way better job
way better sure fool who they got left
would you listen who is on your list joe
joe biden does come across as
like a bit of a cowboy in a way doesn't
he well you just shut up man
he's old schoolers he's always he is old
school i mean he's all of the dirt
it's clear that joe biden has a lot of
contempt
for donald trump donald trump just has
contempt for everyone a lot of people
died
and a lot more gonna die unless he gets
a lot smarter a lot quicker
mr president did you use the word smart
uh so you said you went to delaware
state but you forgot the name of your
college
address the point like we're saying that
people are dying here and your ego is so
inflamed it's incredible the fact that
he's pulling him up on
where he finished in college is instead
of saying oh no people haven't died it's
just amazing
if you would have had the charge of what
i was put through i had to close
the greatest economy in the history of
our country and by the way now it's
being built again
it's an interesting point would they
have dealt with it better there's no way
of knowing
you will never know have they don't have
both sides of the atlantic dealt with
this terribly i don't know
let's hear from boris johnson and see
what boris has to say give him a fair
crack of the whip that's what we've done
that's all we're here for by the way
those two are men mumbling each other
one of them is going to be the leader of
the free world soon god lord that's
mental you say god lord good lord
he's so shocked he's in another words
god please help me god
help me god jesus baby jesus please
do something if he is going to come back
now would be a [__] good time
last week i explained that the number of
covered patients going into hospital had
doubled in a fortnight
from one person to two the context boris
context oh no this is what boris johnson
is very good at
listen when boris johnson started with
covid people said he was invoking
churchill
this man can barely invoke jonah hill at
this point like it's unbelievable what
is going on
i would love to join the hill i would
like honestly wouldn't it be great but
the version of him where he drank the
goldfish
yeah that version yeah i want that guy
sorting out corvid
ahead of boris to be fair they say it's
very similar behind the scenes
yeah so that's why we announced the
package of restrictions
and stronger enforcement i've been a
victim of that some of
the strong their enforcement had a
policewoman tell me to mask up the day i
was going to the train station i was
about 10 meters away from
anyone else yeah come running over to me
gotta put your mask on gotta put your
mask on i was like i'm not on the train
yet she's like oh no it's because it's
in an enclosed
space yeah i mean it's literally like a
[__] arena yeah the train station but
um
i could see she was really like getting
off on that moment of telling someone
what to do
what she didn't realize is i like being
told what to do for a woman so we were
both winning right and then you said
let me bend you over this bench no no no
no no
it was sad in my head because i was like
i could see your your coming in your
puns
bossing someone around right now it's a
bit awkward because in my head i thought
it's sad really because you've probably
got your job wanting to catch
actual criminals and instead you're just
doing sort of nazi work
really now by running over telling
people how you must go and i'm not
anywhere near anyone you actually come
over to me and got close to me
yeah she was right well little does she
know well there were there were three
pounds of weed in his bag
normally while you're busy trying to
catch them normally when a woman's
telling me what to do wearing a mask
it's a completely different scenario
right okay yeah
you turned to her and you went join me
put the mask on i put the ball gag in
we've been intensifying the local
lockdowns in areas
where the disease has been flaring up
and i won't say i know
how tough it is and has been for these
communities
no you absolutely don't know how tough
it has been yeah when you're keeping
your
balls open in parliament or [__] 10
o'clock or whatever the [__] they did is
that after 10 years
they're allowed to do what they want the
only place yeah the only place in
britain you can drink beyond why is he
not wearing a mustache the [__] way
well he's not close to anyone else
and what you don't know is this is
actually outside
i wish i could tell you tonight that the
impact of this package
has already begun to appear i love the
fact that he says that to his wife as
well yeah the impact of this package
has already begun to appear and she goes
deliver the package
captain johnson's flying without a
license oh boris relieve my economy
basically last week boris was telling us
to go
weatherspoons this week he's threatening
us with the army if we do so yeah so
yeah the one thing i like about boris
consistency yeah if there's anything you
can say about boris johnson
he never flips me stuck with one message
exactly yeah exactly you will all die
because of my incompetence yeah exactly
yeah
in many ways yeah he literally someone
the other day said that he went did i
stutter
basically the headline says it all
they're now bringing in laws to
bully us into obeying them are they
substantiated are they fair
doesn't matter because we will not
question them lawrence well we don't
need to
let them get on with it don't question
what i like is my freedoms taken away
from me without any evidence to back up
whether or not they should be at this
stage do you know like three four months
ago when we were locked down
completely get it but at this point why
are we now being bullied into doing
whatever these [__] want to see we
please brian please can we just come
together as a country no no
in fining i won't question anything now
please definitely not
everyone yes i'll do everything you say
mrs policewoman do you want to piss on
my face
would you like that policewoman ah love
it a livery enactment there of what
brian said
to a policewoman in newcastle uh train
station and now
dr brian brianson takes us through the
numbers last week i
suggested that the covered cases that
were going up that we can
in no way take as actual fact yeah
because
the likelihood is that the case amounts
are a lot higher it's just
we're not able to get the tests yeah my
barber for example
uh needed to get a test to keep his
business open he had to drive
into scotland in order to locate a test
the same day he had to endanger people
within scotland that's how ridiculous it
is so whatever the numbers of cases the
confirmed case
[__] they're way higher yeah what
what that then means
the numbers of people dying in return
they're probably more realistic so this
is the graph that goes back
a few months to when this all kicked off
and you can see the spike in blue
of confirmed cases right once again
probably way way [__] higher
then we're going to lock down yeah and
you can see the numbers come down
now you can see the numbers in red this
is the deaths here and then as you can
see it goes
down down down down into nothingness now
the cases are going back
up but the deaths are obviously going
back up a tiny tiny tiny bit
but not a lot and i suggested last week
before i'd seen this craft that that was
because the vulnerable people the over
65s
who had taken a massive 90 of those
numbers were no longer here and they'd
been taken out very early on
by covid which is why in my opinion the
restrictions that are being put in place
now are ridiculous we've now got a graph
that basically backs up everything i
said last week
i'm just a [__] idea i'm just some
[__] youtube guy i don't know why the
one i'm the one who's having to [__]
say i don't even want to have to use my
platform for this but
no [__] youtubers are saying hardly
and the politicians are talking absolute
[__]
they're removing our freedoms away from
us on the basis of confirmed cases and i
do think that we should pay attention to
that because
we don't want the nhs overwhelmed again
right but the reality is
the number of deaths is nowhere near the
amount necessary
to to put restrictions on a 66 million
person country
when we're not even in trouble figure
deaths at the moment thank you
dr brian bryanson we've got another
another graph
another rough wow i just found this one
interesting okay because
we're being told corvid corvid covered
be fearful scary scary scary and there
are other things that are
also taking people's lives right and it
just just opposes it between
other viruses all the diseases all the
other things to worry about it brings it
sort of home of how
the media are overreporting one thing
and potentially under reporting other
things so this is the flu deaths
versus the corvid deaths right it seems
quite clear obviously
they're different you know they're going
to leave different lasting effects and
i'm not trying to get into which illness
is generally deadlier yeah he's got a
worse illness
i'm i'm literally just talking about the
reporting of these and how
we're being spoken to in our way
digesting this information right you've
got the flu death in blue
corvid in orange flu consistently it's
horrible for the
people of this country yeah you've got
the massive spike in orange from kovid
and then it comes right down and as you
can see it's gone a tiny bit higher
recently
but flu is now killing more people now
regardless of that it's the way we're
being spoken
that is not being reported right now
it's corvid corvid covey be fearful of
it this is the worst thing
right now flew is killing more people
flu is currently more deadlier
and we're just not being spoken due that
way and it makes me wonder why
and i think in a few years this will all
be more clear why isn't there more
transparency i guess
you're asking why are we tr why are we
being treated like we live in north
korea sometimes
you can't do that well it would be great
if you are actually
treating me as a human not as a number
chrissy teigen
posted this picture which is powerful
um she is the partner of john legend
yeah
and they were expecting a baby and sadly
uh the baby didn't make it through the
pregnancy they went in
expecting obviously to have that lovely
experience came out without a child
this happens to many hopeful parents out
there and it happened to a celebrity
and i think good on her for posting
publicly about it because a lot of
people are going to feel like it only
happens to them and it doesn't happen to
celebrities and it's happening to these
people and she's just pouring all that
emotion out there you know when you went
through
you know having your kid i was sort of
worried and you know you everyone you're
always worried at the better end no
doubt yeah this
this happens this is real life and it's
just [__] awful so i just thought we
had to put
this in the video i also think when
obviously we've covered a lot of people
in this video we want you to see
only their makeup side their fake side
this is a very real thing that dude yeah
this is
especially so soon after ida kid when i
saw that this morning i was really quiet
that is one of the most like
touching photographs you could see like
that is her just raw
devastated john legend posted about it
as well just saying like because they've
named the baby
jack i love you jack that sort of thing
it's just [__] devastating i don't
there's not really anything we can say
other than that like but i just thought
we have to mention it because these two
people are
they're huge in america and they've gone
through this yeah so even if we didn't
know who they were i'd still feel
terrible for them it's terrible in other
graphic
relationship news i don't really have to
put this this guy basically found his
wife cheating and then forced his wife
to cut off the guy's
head that she was cheating with wow he
definitely laid hands on her as well by
the looks of it this is a kind of lesson
to a lot of people out there like is it
be careful whose girl you [__] one
minute she's riding this guy's dick
and half an hour later she's cutting his
head off apparently he did force her to
cut her head off and then he beat her oh
does he fall
i'll beat the [__] out of you unless you
cut this guy so next thing you know
she's at it yeah
all right then yeah i mean it's it
sounds to me
wow it sounds to me a lot like this guy
is uh one sick [__]
i mean but she's also a bit odd to go
through with it she was cheating but at
the same time she [__] the guy and
then she cut his head off yeah
i don't think he came in and went oh my
god what are you doing she went i'll cut
his head off i'll cut his head off
she suggested it or anything she went
i'm sorry
[__] man we could not put this in this
is one of the weirdest stories we've
ever read it's true
i hate it when when girls post i'd like
to like [__]
hate men or whatever right and then you
see a girl do this [__] and i'm like
you lot yeah yeah you should be ashamed
of yourselves
now i know you love train spotting and i
know you love harry potter so
what is going to make you more
frustrated than this
train's coming so this is the hogwarts
express imagine the hogwarts express
oh [__] sake unfortunately
[Music]
honestly when i [__] saw this i
thought it was so funny
it's blocked it all over the whole thing
wait for it wait for it and then they've
missed it
i [__] love it i absolutely love it
it is amazing the shitholi is perfect
now do you remember when i went on a
podcast a couple of months ago uh with
anthony i do
one of after he's just made a video
about me this guy talks me up so nicely
yeah we gotta give him a shout out bless
him he's um thank you to my youtube
daddy
right some other girls actually made uh
similar videos but they didn't make it
into the video so
yeah they're personal we don't talk
about it exactly um he did a podcast
with you
and a few of the other couple of the
other guys he's also done with leaving
bruce with elliot with a couple of guys
and his podcasts are really great
podcasts
um he's a great interviewer and
obviously he's got cerebral palsy or
something
yeah and and obviously uh he and i've
kind of worked up like a little
friendship so he messages me quite
regularly i message him quite regularly
and he just kind of asked pogba to be
fair don't message me just because
you've got cerebral palsy doesn't mean
i'm gonna change for you yeah absolutely
yeah that's a really great point
you know what though i actually
genuinely i said that to anthony and
anthony was like ryan's
uh everyone yeah exactly my favorite bit
was where he accidentally starts
slagging the sidemen off and then
realizes it
is so funny i really am a big true
georgie
fan and he's just a really nice guy
yeah anthony you've not met him behind
the scenes he goes into that he says
not too nice right okay i'm sure
sometimes
he can be a prick as we all can i think
that's
nice they give me a freak could you see
guys
like the sign men and they i know
disrespect to them
but a lot of them come across as
disingenuous
okay i we've all seen it we've all seen
it let's be honest
assignment the signmen fans
are crazy
oh finally someone said it right we love
the sidemen but their fans are mentally
totally right
i can't wait you say anything about the
sidemen the cop that me
it's not even worth it i can't wait to
see circa's furious reply to this on his
next set of videos you bust up you
bastard who the [__] is this
a lot of them are crazy it's just me the
females
that they're really crazy
to be fair brian i now see why he's one
of your fans i love this yeah
and just typically i'm not trying to dig
out the sign then i'm just saying too
late
too late you've already gone on a
five-minute retirement no chance of the
side man on your podcast
when they say this they're going to be
rich
how did i get under the sign then the
point is
i loved friends authenticity i love you
too brother if you want to slag the
sidemen off don't let me interrupt you
mate
you get on with it can i show you it's
so lovely anthony then went on
to watch us watching blue van man uh one
thing anthony didn't do was get rid of
his um
tabs i'm glad there's no porn i'm really
glad there's no point there
he loves the porn there is some sidemen
up there there isn't there so yeah he's
been watching this
exactly maybe just to rage a little bit
if you hate watches then yeah exactly i
do like
thumbs down all the time you can always
enjoy cheddars
there's nothing wrong nothing offensive
or anything about a cheddar
nothing offensive about children
i love i love the fact that we're
laughing and he's like i love how happy
it makes him but what i love is he's
actually
such a nice guy but every now and again
he catches himself almost being too nice
and here's one time where he's a bit too
nice
i'm sorry if i annoy you with my laugh
that's the way i laugh no i'm not sorry
because it's our laugh and if you've got
a problem in that then it's not my fault
i love what a badass this guy is but you
have these thoughts though
yeah it makes a video how's these
thoughts where you go you know i don't
want them to think this i don't
think that but obviously he's just
getting into being a youtuber and he's
starting to realize [__] it
yeah [__] it me anthony keep making the
videos we love you shout out to anthony
podcast he's called his channel
727 subs let's get him over the thousand
yeah what are the chances of
you know you being born right with the
name anthony podcast there's been lauren
in your life tonight
it's been so lucky right folks we are
back in the van back in the van back in
the van
i like that today uh we are stopping the
night at
the cricketers um you what's that don't
i know you were opening it like on the
[__] angle you've already got cream
on me see
the day sorry dave yeah you set this up
nothing wrong with a [__] in the van
though so what we've done we've just
walked through the streets and we've
found a street
market that uh does a food market
nothing like
wuhan no one thought it was like
so i've had a chinese curry ironic
nothing like we've had but i went for
the chinese option
there it is folks for the visually
impaired i'm all i'm showing you the
chicken curry
sorry yeah what are you looking at no
i'm not
gonna squeeze your line well then squish
squeeze your line squeeze me on
these two have got so much sexual
tension i love it you imagine she still
goes
come on dave let's go upstairs and he's
like oh all over oh go on then
you're starting out to uh oh no they are
um
they really do flip sexual i love how
much they flirt with each other even now
let's
tuck the [__] in
come on go on then
oh [__] oh that's good please can we
go out for a meal with dave
i want to go out for a meal with dave
and joe phil in june yeah and just have
a lovely evening out we'll literally
make it like a podcast
but over a meal that makes sense you
could just do it around yeah yeah yeah
well i know you don't like leaving house
it's the practicalities of filming it
isn't it imagine
what i think about production lawrence
well you know i don't do that but admit
i do love blue van man
uh go over subscribe to his channel he's
on 122k and that was true news
for you lot this sunday though it's
manchester united
versus spurs we're live on the kick off
on the true jordan youtube channel from
four all the boys are going to be there
we're going to be talking all the
football it's going to be good
hit the foot in a like button hit the
subscribe button if you have enjoyed
this episode
and we'll see you is on the kickoff